i'm enjoying
the negativity because it's become such
a [ __ ]
thing i'm used to that when joy is put
into my life
it's like confusing and i just start
crying and [ __ ] getting
lost i don't know what to [ __ ] do
i'm not ready for change i guess
like if i had a self-destruct button i
just probably [ __ ] hit it right now
all right john john where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
i'm from chicago tell me about your
family you had both parents when you
were a kid
my mom she's just been kind of like
using me for child support money on and
off
uh dad in and out of jail uh his last
case was for 12 atm highest he played
guilty too
close a couple cases and basically get a
shorter sentence
i've been on and off the street from
like 16
on what was your what was your childhood
like uh
just kicked out of school after school
going between parents grandparents
and shelter
basically i don't know exactly where it
started
between getting touched or abused
i mean i had a pretty wild stepdad that
didn't favor me out of the bunch and
like even if
i was in the right it was looked at as a
wrong
i remember like being dragged and picked
up by a belt around my neck
shaking and throwing across the room at
the bed
hitting the wall in between the bed and
the floor
just led to a drug use at a young age
and even more
pedophilic people being around me
uh when did you come to l.a
about three to four years ago i'd say
how do you know 28 20
and you're staying on skid row yeah i'm
staying in a tent
next to my brother uh
what's your drug today uh fentanyl every
now and then i do black
i smoke crystal and lately i've been
kind of like
messing around with sherm but not really
and drug you started
what age for you oh man like nine years
old
i'd say i found my dad's weed at a young
age
and like i didn't even know what i was
doing i tried rolling up in computer
paper
and almost caught my closet on fire uh
then i started doing coke then really
quickly turned to crack cocaine
where i was me and my dad were just
picking up like an ounce a day to two
ounces a day
selling it to like my friends and [ __ ]
and then
i was also doing acid shrooms ecstasy
just every day was a different drug and
me chasing the drug
weather pills what everything i've had
my like dip in
everything what do you what would you
put your finger on as
being the reason that you started with
drug use
disassociation from my kid
you know missing him was trump yeah i
mean lately
like i've been like having problems
coping with emotions
and like i think it does have something
to do with like being raped but like
it comes out in bits and pieces
and like i'm not i don't know exactly
how to put it like
i'm emotional on a day to day i'm a
wreck and i wake up just constantly the
first thing i think about is suicide
like you know my friends look at me like
i'm crazy
i can't even really talk to him about it
this happens to you every day
yeah every single day i actually this
morning
every time you call first thing and then
i have to clean up after everybody
well everybody else just doesn't give a
[ __ ] i'm
constantly being put to spread the
stress and pressure on
the most about cleaning the block and
taking care of
everybody else while dealing with mental
issues
that nobody gives a [ __ ] about
it's just it's [ __ ] haywire
how are you supporting yourself now i
boost i go out every day
i rob stores i go in with trash bags
sometimes and i just start filling up in
front of the security and
you know tracing me around the store a
little bit and i'll [ __ ]
play cat and mouse and then i'll run out
the store
and then i'll go to [ __ ] i'm not
gonna see the area but you know i go
sell it to the mexicans and
i get my little money and i go get my
fix defenses
yeah fences they're called fences yeah
yeah
uh and that's how you support yourself
yeah that and i mean here and there
prostitution
uh when it's i see like
profitable like
which is had me like also questioning
sexuality
whether i'm straight or not so it's
confusing
so you're basically a straight male but
you're yeah you're being
propositioned you're giving an
opportunity to make money yeah from
other males
it's making it make me wonder am i
straight you know and like
i look at other gays and i'm like okay
when did you
become gay and i've been gay my whole
life and i'm like that's not the case
with me
you know i still like women but
i could get erect for a male
and i don't know if that's the drugs
doing it or if it's just the
so much of abuse and like
i just kind of zone out during the time
and just get it done
you know i take that pain and i just go
on with it
um really no more than i could say that
i could do with that part uh besides
take it
when you when you need a fix and you got
to get it you got to get it at that
point when
when it gets to the point where you're
so sick and you can't think
it's like you got a demon on your
shoulder and you got an angel on your
shoulder
and the angel is just constantly getting
pushed off the shoulder and the devil is
just [ __ ]
standing tall you know he's just like
[ __ ] it
what is it what is your [ __ ]
sexuality what is
you know another day of abuse you you
could be [ __ ] high for three four
days
and not have to think about it
what do you think others that don't do
drugs
don't understand about addiction
everything
i i i look at other people and i feel
like i'm not even a human anymore
but the the power of it like people will
say well
you know you speak intelligently you
seem like an educated person and you're
making these decisions that are so
self-destructive
and now sometimes i'm just suicidal i
guess i've just been so like hate
towards myself for like giving up on my
kid
even though i really don't want to you
know
it's just i can't i can't be there for
him and i did a lot to [ __ ]
make my [ __ ] on point you know
with schooling and working and then when
my dad just didn't give a [ __ ] and then
the blackmailing and the the baby mama
thinking i'm [ __ ] some black girl
that was way before
her but she every time [ __ ] go [ __ ]
that black [ __ ]
i'm not doing [ __ ] i'm in school and you
think i'm [ __ ] doing some
i'm in school i'm working i'm coming
taking off the day getting out
by my boss to take you to the hospital
for a twisted [ __ ] ankle
and then i gotta go and you're just like
all right i'm gonna do me
what do you mean you're gonna do you
what did i do to deserve that you know
so i just i eventually stopped talking
to her and it's it's become this point
where like i don't know how to get
back into my son's life you know i don't
know how to jump back in and start a
conversation with him because he's like
getting older
and it's just terrifying to me and
that's that's bringing so much [ __ ]
stress
yeah total [ __ ] shame i feel like
such a [ __ ] loser
you know i feel everybody looks at me
too
you know every now and then i [ __ ] i
might be bipolar and i might get into a
different like superman mode where like
i'm
making money but like it doesn't
continually
stay that way or escalate to where i'm
making it you know i'm always
in between the [ __ ]
and a fix
i feel like my whole life is gonna
continue down this
until i [ __ ] deteriorate
my son won't even know who the [ __ ] i am
have any friends yeah i i gotta have a
very large amount of friends
actually i consider more of like a
basically highly organized
trade market more like we get high
together
we share our stories kind of you know
but at the end of the day we're all
trying to get somewhere
you know so we really don't give a [ __ ]
about each other we'd probably turn our
backs on each other
more than we [ __ ] shake hands so
they're more like acquaintances than
friends
yeah yeah
do you feel like you were ever loved
when you were young when you were a
child
yeah for for a small period of time in
my life
until my grandpa he had a secret life
going on with black girl from georgia
and like he just randomly brought her
to greece with us when we went out there
for the summer
and that was last year i went out there
he's just like surprise this is my
daughter this is her daughter
this is your dad's sister and i
like it felt like that point that's when
everything went downhill
it didn't bother me so much but it's
almost like a curse was put on my family
i don't know it's very weird
nobody even seen it coming you know
uh my dad he seemed to know about it
though
he was okay with it my grandma she's
torn up by it
led her into [ __ ] mental
deterioration physical deterioration
she died young grandpa got to go retire
he just recently died this year
out in retirement in greece on an island
called milos
this island i go out every year up until
2008
at that at that point i was a mockery to
the family
name basically i was an alcoholic out
there most kids would be like oh i'm in
greece and they go swimming blah blah
i was trying to get drunk every [ __ ]
minute
and i sunk a boat i [ __ ]
was punching out windows and just
showing like weird signs that like
something wasn't right and instead of
trying to fix it
like i was shunned like i was looked at
like
actually made fun of it and as i recall
you know they would call me little
jessica
or they refer to my parents names
which they're they're [ __ ] idiots
you know like
the family on greece they just act a lot
higher
than what i was or my family was so we
all just got outcasted nobody got to
talk to them
nobody knew what happened the only
reason i know that my grandpa died was
because i kept up with social media and
other people posting on his profile
i'm actually named after him you know so
it's it's pretty [ __ ] up to see
like his last several years i didn't
even get to talk to him
you know it's crazy how some small [ __ ]
in somebody's life
somebody would just give up on you
just throw you out like you're trash
do you have hope for your future
i did but like nowadays i just feel like
everything's a waste of time
i used to have dreams i used to think i
could make music i just think i could
draw new tattoos and i know i could cook
but
i don't want to be everybody's [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] time and [ __ ]
clean this and cook that and barely show
any appreciation towards
like for cooking like anybody could
[ __ ] cook
it's a very simple thing you know you
put somebody in the kitchen a year or
two later the man's a cook
you know that's all that happened there
you know [ __ ]
even if i had like all the [ __ ] funds
imaginable to make my career that i
wanted back when i was younger i would
probably just waste more time doing
drugs
nowadays it just seems like my dog is
the only thing i got
and even there i'm like considering
selling her just to get high
and it's [ __ ] up cause i've spent a
lot of money on her
just to throw it all away
i don't know it just seems like there's
nothing you can do
to cast these demons out of you once
they're in you they just keep getting
at you until you've had enough and
it just isn't a comment it's not
something you're saying under your
breath
you just eventually take your life has
depression always been
something you've dealt with or is
because the first time i tried killing
myself was like nine years old
i was impatient i was in i had to get
sent to utah salt lake city
at 13 and do a [ __ ] inpatient there i
got kicked out for giving a kid a
concussion
making his jaw pop every time it opened
after pissing on his head and waking him
up
i don't know i i i feel psychotic like
most the time
actually i'm not only the abused i'm the
abuser
like people say like the person that
gets abused eventually becomes that
person
i sometimes feel like i'm becoming that
person
and like my whole life i've just thought
i'm gonna be that dog that ends up in a
[ __ ] cell and there's nothing i could
do it's just gonna eventually lead to me
killing people every time i get within
contact with people
or self-isolation just locked in a
[ __ ] cell
if not not even a cell there's no
[ __ ] bars it's just a [ __ ]
cement room or a little tiny window
with your food thrown at you
soaking in your own piss and sweat
and the life you're living now doesn't
really help
there's no other choice though no i know
i mean just just to survive you need to
steal or
have sex with guys yeah
sex with anything [ __ ] too
anything i literally can zone out and do
basically what ketamine does to the body
without ketamine
like everything's just gone and i could
put on a persona of somebody that i'm
not just
a [ __ ] achievement objective to lead
to my [ __ ] numbing
have you ever had therapy yeah uh it
never seemed to help though
i always just i mocked it i thought it
was stupid
i just everyday has seen it as like oh
everybody let's go to group and let's
write our goals and just
just [ __ ] [ __ ] talking about it
does not
[ __ ] help it just brings it back into
my brain
and it makes me sit and ponder on it
like more
than just letting it go and trying to
push it away
you know it really just seems like the
drug is the only thing that cures it
nowadays
that's the only thing
you know i
the whole time it's just even then
suicide actually really
is all i could i've been thinking about
just doing just
getting myself out of this life
just [ __ ] the drugs really the drug is
just temporary
you ever been clean very short period of
time and
i was a cook and i offered my baby mama
to come move out to georgia
and be a stay-at-home mom and she'd just
rather stay in chicago in the [ __ ]
cut in the ghetto
and [ __ ] raise her son amongst
different
dudes that she just bounces off of
getting abused by
and then i snapped and said all right
[ __ ] this what am i working for
i can't keep my son back she's will i'm
willing to work with me
and she's i'm just constantly putting
out as this bad person so
[ __ ] it i'm gonna become the bad person
i'm not gonna be called something i'm
not
you know and
just people day to day like i can't
stand people
i really can't like i eat my own friends
i tell them to shut the [ __ ] up and i
feel like killing them
even when they're trying to be
compassionate with me and show me the
time that i need
like it's just i'll be out of my head
and so [ __ ]
much filth i can't stand it and i
literally just snap
second i wake up i start snapping so the
second i go to bed do you ever have good
days
no not really
i always seem to find like the
depression and everything
more than like the joy
everything just i could always since a
young age without the news
having to be played and just see
everything that's going around
with corona and all this stupid [ __ ]
i could see it like physically like
the good and evil in life but
i'm almost enjoying the evil like
i'm enjoying the negativity because it's
become such a [ __ ]
thing i'm used to that when joy is put
into my life
it's like confusing and i just start
crying and [ __ ] getting
lost i don't know what to [ __ ] do
i'm not ready for change i guess
like if i had a self-destruct button i
just probably [ __ ] hit it right now
you ever talked to a doctor about brain
chemistry or anything like that
i've studied brain chemistry psychology
yeah well doctors have studied chemistry
and they're still experimenting
[ __ ] the last [ __ ] trick that i was
pulling was a psychiatrist
used to write [ __ ] zany bars off to
people
you know it just shows how many
pedophilic people they're out in this
world even the [ __ ] richest
and like people that are looked at as
high and
mighty can be the [ __ ] most weirdest
and tormenting to some of the most
[ __ ] fragile people out here
because you don't see them on a
day-to-day basis you don't see them when
they're
hey you fool around you want to [ __ ] me
in my ass
like you know what kind of question
you're asking me do you know what that
does to my brain when i hear that
it makes me want to like contemplate
killing you and dragging you off into
under a sewer plate and dropping you
into the [ __ ] ground
i think about that daily actually i
think about hunting people
daily i think about going out and
killing people daily and my friends
actually i could even get my friends to
probably join me
i feel like [ __ ] manson like
only targeting more the pedophilic
nature like
every time i get whiff of somebody
that's supposedly a little more [ __ ]
psychotic
i almost want to go out and kill him i
just got wind of somebody that
supposedly tried burning up a 13 year
old girl's body after raping her and
killing her
lives right down the street from here
and he's still [ __ ] running around
the street
i just want to go kill him my friend
wants to go kill him
he's been raped too [ __ ] a lot of my
friends have been put through the same
[ __ ] and they can understand and that's
what's even more disgusting it's like
i'm not just an outcast i'm maybe not
just one out of [ __ ] a million no i'm
like one out of [ __ ]
99 and there's maybe one percent people
out here that are [ __ ] normal and it
just seems that they're all normal
sorry i zoned out for a second i don't
know what i was thinking about
you got a lot of dark stuff going on in
your head yeah
i sometimes zone out a lot yeah
i i don't know i can't hear voices too
but i can't tell if they're like really
hearing them or i am and like people
that's another reason i snap on people
like they'll be saying [ __ ] but they
don't
like make themselves loud enough to we
can hear them so then like my brain
confuses me
into making it think that they're saying
something sexual towards me under their
breath so nobody else hears it
and i threatened to kill this dude the
other day who we hang out with on a
daily basis
like because he's just mumbling you know
he smokes crystal he can't really be
heard
and i thought you were saying something
about my dick or his dick or something
i'm like you want to say it a little
louder so i have a reason to [ __ ] cut
your throat
because i'll drag you out [ __ ] butt
ass snake and throw you out this tent
and have your little dick in the wind
well i beat you to [ __ ] death in the
middle of the street
and i honestly am not afraid to go to
jail like
i'm almost welcoming it
it's probably the place i belong
i feel like a possible threat you know i
need to be put out
my misery so i don't destroy more lives
that don't deserve to be destroyed
you know part of me doesn't want to be
that abuser but like i just can't help
it
it's too much overriding the brain
and it's just doing what it knows
what it sees what it hears
monkey see monkey do
[Music]
would you consider going to a mental
health place and seeing what they
can do to help you honestly no
the only way you're going to get me in a
little room is by locking me in the
little room
because i want to be numb i can't
[ __ ] handle sitting there
dealing with the [ __ ] and people
that don't really give a [ __ ] they're
there for a paycheck
no but but somebody that might give you
a medication that might help i've
tried medications they they they're so
[ __ ] stupid they don't even know what
the [ __ ] they're prescribing me half the
time this dude [ __ ] prescribed me
twice
with [ __ ] that was like knocking me out
and then they were yelling at me for
knocking out
like i couldn't control it literally i
was physically blacking out
i was in group and like literally i was
like kicked out of the whole pizza party
and everything and i flipped out and
destroyed the whole [ __ ] unit and
left rehab
because of some idiot just just
prescribing me whatever
well we're going to give you debit card
and nissanet and
we'll see how you act and we'll read
your charts and
go on forth from there
i could [ __ ] and lie because i'm
confused at the time
and just get me put into taking more
medications that
don't really physically help because i
want to get out of there at the time
so i will tell you oh yeah everything's
all right
i'm totally ready to leave but really i
might be that killer today
i might come out in these streets and
[ __ ] kill somebody if i see enough
money in their [ __ ] hand
you think talking about it helps you or
hurts you i don't know honestly
it feels like the blood is getting to my
head and like i'm gonna black out
when i think this much i'll give you a
break and we'll
put a stop to it today but if you want
to come back
sure you're welcome to come back there's
somebody else that i talked to james
when i first started doing this that had
really really dark thoughts all the time
he claimed he was uh killing pedophiles
on the street i probably know him
i'll show you a photo or i'll show you a
video on it i'd love to see it
he has a lot of dark stuff going on
there's a lot of gay guys coming up
missing actually
not missing found actually their hands
handcuffed pants below their waist
throat cut and it's
believed to be a serial killer right by
where i was staying because they found
the body right one block away
and then there was also a dude killing
all the girls that do fentanyl macarthur
park
but he disappeared for a while i don't
know where he's at
i don't know if i'd kill him or if i'd
join him
you know i'd honestly first want to see
why if he's killing pedophiles yeah then
that's
all the power to him you know
but then eventually there's got to be
the point where i got to kill myself
because i'm starting to become that sick
demented [ __ ]
that'll probably pay some [ __ ] hoe to
[ __ ] do some crazy [ __ ] to me
you know and not will have i've already
done like i've done
stupid [ __ ] with my money throwing it
away
sexually
to just [ __ ] be miserable still you
know it doesn't really
complete or make me feel like i complete
any goal
you know and i [ __ ] some bad [ __ ]
but
these [ __ ] there's you know they're
so [ __ ]
confusing in the way they come on they
make you confused about your own
sexuality
you may they make you think that they
care and they're compassionate and like
that's what you need you don't need some
[ __ ] that's going to keep [ __ ]
running around cheating on you and
making you want to go after and
[ __ ] choke her out you know maybe
it's not about the sex anymore it's just
about that [ __ ]
maturity and someone to talk to that
cares and is on the same level
but then it always comes back to the sex
they want to do something weird to you
i've been drugged i have people try to
drug me
a lot of the time actually shh [ __ ]
hand me sherm sticks
when they're passing a normal one around
and make it seem like they're gonna pass
me normal one but then it's not
like i don't know the difference and i
can't smell it you know
i've smoked bath salt accidentally once
this gay dude [ __ ] handed it to me
and i didn't know i was the only one
smoking it
they were smoking another pipe i started
freaking out for like two three days
i couldn't handle the hearing like every
little
vision or like reflection of me looked
demonic like it wasn't me looking back
at myself
and i literally just wanted to find a
hill in the middle of nowhere where it
just was quiet
and i could just zone away from that
i had people trying to turn me in the
inpatient because i was like literally i
wouldn't come down
for like two three days after that point
i was in portland at that time
i've stayed in washington i've stayed in
portland i've stayed in california
basically all of the [ __ ] west coast
have stayed in idaho
and some of the east coast too [ __ ]
west coast always seemed to be more
[ __ ]
life-threatening
you know what's been the worst
neighborhood you've stayed in
[ __ ] my own chicago
i mean there's never a day where
you can't find everybody that you're
in relation to to walk down the street
just to get something without getting
jumped
or the police stopping you and being
like hey we had a jump thing going on
and you're suspected of being the
leading result of that
because your tattoos or whatever and i'm
just trying to get a 2 liter and get
back to the grill
and maintain my fire and my food and now
i got to come back to burnt ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] because they want to [ __ ]
prosecute me for some [ __ ] that i didn't
even do with neighborhood in chicago
cicero
it's it became though
between me and my family being a part of
one gang
and then staying out of a house of
my dad's friend who is in another gang
they're rivals
but we low-key click
you know it was very hard to do and
control because other people did not
like that and
it had to be though you know we had
nowhere to stay
you know that was after my dad going
m.i.a
from the [ __ ]
basically what he started because he was
becoming a crackhead it was against the
[ __ ] gang rules you know like
they didn't preach that whole [ __ ]
that people are out on here they don't
give a [ __ ]
you know every gang like i've come
across gangs where like
they don't give a [ __ ] if one of your
members is a rapist or this or that they
don't care
you're not there we take care of that
[ __ ] you know
and you better take care of that [ __ ] if
you see it otherwise you'll be [ __ ]
beat for it you know there's constant
violations over nothing
violations for not going to church
violations church is [ __ ] basically
meet up
time you know once out the week
everybody has to come in and [ __ ]
relay on what's going the [ __ ] on if you
see anything going on in the hood
anything that needs to be dealt with
it's a very uh white gang
you know started in the 60s but it's
like
now starting to show more like puerto
rican members and some black members
is in chicago yeah simon city royals
[ __ ] it's kind of branched out
and it's becoming something that wasn't
back then but
i've kind of like escaped that life
i was sick of it and
i just didn't want to go on anymore i
was controlling my life
like i didn't have a choice and if i
did try to open my mouth and say like oh
yeah i don't feel like it right now
like man you mean a [ __ ] dog come on
like you're gonna let me [ __ ] go deal
with this [ __ ] by myself
after you've been riding with me this
whole time like
there is no none of that no when you
join in you join in and it's
sacrifice to the [ __ ] human soul
you know you literally put your life on
the line
i guess that's kind of where like coming
in with the killing pedophilic
people off like we don't like that
nature you know that's just
it's shunned you know anything gay is
shown really
is very unliberal in chicago
all right john well thank you for coming
in and
talking with me if you want to come back
anytime definitely let me know
because you have a lot going on in your
head no i do yeah
you